.
BRIAN: NEW YORK GOVERNOR ANDREW
CUOMO REVELING THAT THEY’RE
DROPPING THEIR INVESTIGATION
INTO NURSING HOME DEATHS.
>> IT WAS TOXIC POLITICS.
IT VIOLATED THE BASIC CONCEPT OF
JUSTICE IN THIS NATION.
AND IT DID A LOT OF HARM AND A
LOT OF DAMAGE.
TO SAY TO PEOPLE WHO LOST A
LOVED ONE IN A NURSING HOME IT
COULD HAVE BEEN APPRECIATED.
IT WAS A MISTAKE BY GOVERNMENT
BUREAUCRATS.
THAT’S WHY YOUR LOVED ONE DIED.
HOW CRUEL.
BRIAN: WOW, OUR NEXT GUEST BOTH
LOST FAMILY MEMBERS IN NURSING
HOMES DUE TO THE GOVERNOR’S
POLICIES.
JOINING ME NOW IS OUR VERY OWN
METEOROLOGIST JANICE DEAN AND
RON KIM WHO HAVE BECOME FAST
FRIENDS THROUGH THIS AND ALLIES
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO GET TO THE
TRUTH.
FIRST OFF, JANICE FOR YOU, WAS
THIS THE RIGHT TIME FOR HIM TO
SAY HE WAS EXONERATED?
JANICE: NO.
I’M SO USED TO THIS AND I’M SURE
RON WILL SAY THE SAME THING.
IS HE LIKE A BROKEN RECORD.
HE BLAMES EVERYBODY ELSE EXCEPT
THE GUY WHO SIGNED THE MANDATE
FOR 46 DAYS TO PUT COVID
POSITIVE PATIENTS INTO THE
NURSING HOMES.
THE "NEW YORK POST" THIS MORNING
GOT IT ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
HERE IT IS.
>> LIAR.
HE IS A LIAR.
BRIAN: THEY CHRONICLE THIS, RON
KIM.
BRIAN: RON, WHAT EXACTLY DID THE
DOJ DO AND WHAT EXACTLY IS LEFT
TO THESE INVESTIGATIONS?
FIRST INTO THE NURSING HOMES?
>> DOJ CLOSED THE ORIGINAL
INVESTIGATION.
THAT’S INTO THE PUBLICLY RUN
FACILITIES.
WHICH IS A VERY SMALL PORTION OF
THE ENTIRE NURSING HOME
INDUSTRY.
THE CIVIL INVESTIGATION IS STILL
OPEN FOR THE ENTIRE NURSING
HOMES AND THE CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION, MORE IMPORTANTLY,
IS STILL ONGOING.
FOR THE GOVERNOR TO TAKE THE
MEDIA, NATIONAL STAGE AND TAKE A
VICTORY LAP AND PLAY THE VICTIM
WHILE THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES LIKE
JANICE AND MINE STILL SEEKS THE
TRUTH, THAT IS WHAT IS CRUEL.
BRIAN: HERE IS THE THING MELISSA
DER ROSA CHIEF OF STAFF TOLD
LAWMAKERS ON A CALL BASICALLY
APOLOGIZED FOR STONEWALLING WHEN
IT COME TO THE TOTAL DEATHS.
ON THE RECORD.
IS HE GOING TO THROW HER UNDER
THE BUS?
>> HE WILL DO WHATEVER HE HAS TO
DO, SAY AND DO TO SAVE HIS OWN
BEHIND.
IS HE A DANGEROUS MAN THAT’S
DROWNING.
AND WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO HOLD
HIM ACCOUNTABLE.
HE THINKS THIS IS TOXIC
POLITICS?
THIS IS NOT POLITICS.
THIS ACCOUNTABILITY SO WE CAN
GET THE STATE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION SO WE DON’T REPEAT THE
SAME MISTAKES.
BRIAN: JANICE, HE FEELS LIKE HE
HAS BEEN THROWN A LIFE PRESERVER
AND IS NOW ON SHORE.
SHOULD HE FEEL AS THOUGH HE BEAT
ALL THESE INVESTIGATIONS?
WHAT’S LEFT?
>> HE BETTER PREPARE FOR THE
A.G.’S REPORT WHICH IS COMING IN
THE NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS THERE
ARE MULTIPLE INVESTIGATIONS
HERE.
BRIAN: THE NEW YORK ATTORNEY
GENERAL?
JANICE: ABSOLUTELY.
THERE IS AN FBI INVESTIGATION
AND NEW YORK ATTORNEY GENERAL’S
INVESTIGATION THAT’S SUPPOSED TO
COME OUT IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
WEEKS.
I THINK HE HAS TO PREPARE
HIMSELF.
I WOULD LOVE FOR HIM TO TALK TO
VICTIMS’ FAMILIES IN A TOWN HALL
AND TELL US FACE TO FACE THAT HE
IS THE VICTIM.
AND SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
BUT HE WON’T.
BECAUSE HE IS A COWARD AND A
BULLY.
BRIAN: I KNOW YOU GUYS
UNDERSTANDABLY FOCUSED ON THE
PURSING HOMES.
WHAT IS ALSO LEFT, AT LEAST 10
SHOWER.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT ACCUSERS.
GOT 5 MILLION AS AN ADVANCE WAS
THAT.
LIKE HIS BROTHER WHETHER IT CAME
TO TEST.
HOW MUCH DO THESE OTHER
INVESTIGATIONS MATTER?
WHAT’S HE DOING ABOUT HIS OWN
A.G., DEMOCRATIC A.G.
INVESTIGATING HIM?
>> IT’S ALL A PATTERN OF ABUSE
OF POWERFUL AND ABUSE OF
BEHAVIOR HERE.
HE CHASED DOWN A $5 MILLION BOOK
DEAL AT THE PEAK OF THE
PANDEMIC.
THAT IS THE MAIN REASON WHY HE
COMMITTED FRAUD.
HE HIMSELF LAST YEAR, IT IS
CRIMINAL FRAUD TO LIE ABOUT
NURSING HOME DEATH TOLL.
AND THAT IS PRECISELY WHAT HE
DID.
WE NEED TO AGAIN HOLD HIM
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT.
BRIAN: ALL RIGHT, JANICE, IS HE
STARTING TO MARGINALIZE THE
INVESTIGATION BY LATISHA JAMES
USING SURROGATES TO SAY IT’S ALL
POLITICAL.
REAL QUICK?
JANICE: WILL HE IS TRYINGHE IS T
HER INVESTIGATION INTO HIM
SAYING SHE GOING TO RUN FOR
GOVERNOR.
VICTIMS SHAMING THEM AGAIN.
THIS GOVERNOR NEEDS TO GO.
IF NEW YORK DOESN’T UNDERSTAND
THAT YET, WAKE UP.
BRIAN: RIGHT.
HE IS NOT OUT OF THE WOOD.